now to our exclusive interview with
urban magic johnson one of the greatest
basketball players of all time nate just
told us he's his favorite player he won
five nba titles with the la lakers an
olympic gold medal with the 1992 dream
team 30 years ago this week johnson
revealed at a press conference that he
had hiv the virus that can cause aids
the news was a bombshell because at the
time that diagnosis was considered a
death sentence we spoke with johnson at
the waldorf historian los angeles about
his reaction that day and how he got
through it with the support of his wife
cookie
even for hollywood it was perfect
casting the man who single-handedly
produced magical moments on the
basketball court was at the top of his
game when it all disappeared right
before our eyes
a tragic ending to a magical career
because of the
hiv virus that i have attained
i will have to retire from the lakers
let's go back urban 30 years what did
you know about hiv before you were
diagnosed
because what we knew was scary right at
that time
the only thing i knew
if you got aids you you died right and
so i had to really learn a lot about the
disease
hiv as well as aids
had to make sure that
i was open-minded enough to ask a lot of
questions
go get a lot of information from
different people johnson first learned
of his diagnosis after a routine
physical back in 1991.
he was called back home from a preseason
game in utah so that the lakers team
physician dr michael mellman could
deliver the news in person
went straight to dr melman's office and
then that's when he told me
i had hiv and when you first heard those
words what was the thought in your mind
oh i was just devastated i'm asking them
a hundred times are you sure
they say hey we ran the test a couple of
times and
yes you do have hiv
and so i just
lost it right there you know you just
sit there and say what does this mean
am i going to die because i definitely
asked him that
and he said well
you have a chance to live for a long
time with all the new drugs that are
coming down the pipeline but the
toughest thing gail that i had to do was
really drive home and tell cookie it was
hard because i loved her so much and i
and i hated to hurt her
i played against some of the best
basketball players in the world right
i've been in championships i've been in
nine finals so i know pressure
but it was no greater pressure than
driving home to tell her even today is
still the toughest thing i've ever had
to do in my life the johnsons were
married a little over a month when magic
announced his diagnosis and they had
just learned cookie was pregnant the key
moment was when cookie
took the test and the results came back
that her and the baby was fine that was
a huge relief yes yes because i was
scared to death i wanted to make sure
that she was going to be okay the baby
was going to be okay and then i could
move forward with trying to make sure i
was going to be okay irvine magic
johnson attacked the stigma surrounding
hiv with the same passion he displayed
on the court launching the magic johnson
foundation to raise awareness about the
virus then pushing congress and the
white house to spend money to fight the
disease but he's still long for the game
of basketball and his first retirement
would be short-lived even though he had
not played a single regular season game
fans voted him onto the nba all-star
team in 1992 and a few months later he
played on the u.s olympic dream team
it proved to be the right decision
it helped people who were living with
not just hiv and aids but with
any disease that you can live on you can
be and live a productive life
there were mixed reviews about you
coming back controversy over johnson's
return has erupted in the last few weeks
even one of his olympic dream teammates
carl malone expressed fear about having
to play against him in the physical
sometimes bloody nba arena how did you
feel when there was backlash about you
returning with some of the players when
you got hurt yeah i got cut
and i was very upset
at the backlash because i just played
with a lot of the guys who
didn't want me to come back yeah you
know well i just spent three months with
you
playing against you with you
and so now but you got cutting that
changed again
that scared people that scared the crowd
you could just hear
i never want to hurt the game right
so this is a game that i love
and so
if the guys are going to be scared the
fans didn't know so i said you know what
after that game i said i'm just going to
retire johnson returned to the sport he
loved one more time in 1996. i told
cookie i said you know what
maybe i should look at playing one more
time because i want to end it the right
way okay because you never felt it it
ended the right way exactly okay and
that's why i came back i ended it the
way i wanted
it to end after that his focus finally
began to shift oh i missed the game oh
man cookie will tell you
i sit on that couch and watching the
lakers play that was so hard for me you
know because i said i should be out
there
but it wasn't until she came home i tell
you
gail what changed my life and got me
going into business she came home and
said you know what ervin
i'm
mad and i'm upset
you got to be the man that i married
and i
i was like oh my goodness
like you've always wanted to be in
business why are you sitting on this
couch wow
you got to get started so
get out cookie johnson remembers that
moment too
i'm looking at you like this sitting on
this couch that's not the man i married
you know the man i married was a hard
worker
he was changing the world you know he
had all these ideas he had he was so
full of life
i don't know who this is
and you need to get up and figure that
out
irvin and cookie met when they were
students at michigan state university in
the 70s cookie says at first she did not
want to have the press conference
announcing his diagnosis the stigma with
aids at that time people weren't
educated so they thought you couldn't
touch people you couldn't hug people
and i didn't want people to treat us
like we were lepers i still remember the
press conference you're sitting there
that white suit what were you thinking
i was thinking you know be strong and i
wore that white suit for a reason i
didn't want to wear anything dark or
black because to me it's what it
symbolized and the white suit to me
symbolized you know brightness like a
future basically
you know positivity
when he told you how he got it what was
your thought at that time when he said
you know that he had it and it was
probably through sexual context because
he didn't have any blood transfusions or
anything like that it wasn't how he got
it that was important to me
it was
you're possibly going to die
and that trumped everything she really
is a living example irving of for better
or worse in the marriage vows right
don't you think no no
because for some people for better or
worse doesn't include that right you
know right even when we broke up all
those times and i was dating other
people i said i'm gonna make i already
know who i'm a married you did oh i told
all the women that i know who i'm gonna
marry
i bet you were a fun date
i'm really gonna marry her oh oh they
knew they knew what they knew i was
gonna marry cookie there's no doubt who
i was gonna marry with cookie by his
side the 62 year old basketball legend
is a very successful businessman a
loving father and grandfather don't you
feel like this is your city this is my i
do i feel it's your city oh yeah oh yeah
today johnson runs point in the
boardroom as ceo of magic johnson
enterprises
an investment company focused on
providing high quality products and
services to underserved communities do i
dare ask if being a businessman
entrepreneur philanthropist
is better than playing basketball yes
is it better yes it is and how is your
health today oh it's great
still undetectable and so
you have to take medication every day
still yes still cocktail once a day it
went from three times a day now just
once
and so
everything is great andy says no matter
what there's one thing his diagnosis
decades ago could never defeat
that situation wasn't going to change
my attitude and mindset and the person
that i am okay if if i was gonna die i
was gonna die being irving johnson right
and what does that mean being i mean
just being an upbeat person with a good
attitude
um and so
that's just who i am
that is exactly who he is he said most
people said he wouldn't last three or
four years let alone 30. as you see he
certainly credits cookie he says if it
wasn't for cookie i wouldn't be the man
i was today i say here here to that he's
a hero but she certainly is a hero in a
very other way he he admits that without
her he wouldn't have gotten through this
and after that news conference where you
know as you as you heard she didn't want
to have it a group of friends took them
to hawaii so they could just be alone
and they said we'll never forget how we
were embraced at that time it's a
beautiful thing and what an example of
making a marriage work right uh and the
courage there from from magic johnson
you forget in that in that moment rock
hudson the great hollywood actor had
just died five years earlier very
publicly and people really really felt
if you have this you're done yeah
individuals like arthur ashe as well
because of the transfusion um i i think
about kobe bryant because it happened
recently another laker player but it
just rocked sports fans to the core that
he passed away along with the others on
that helicopter it was kind of like that
for magic johnson yeah because we just
all assumed one of the greatest players
is going to die yeah and he's still here
we're happy to say he gets up at 4 30
every day and goes to the gym he's still
working out taking his medication he's
all good and a great businessman too and
a really good businessman knows how to
make money in addition to the magic
johnson foundation you can find
information on hiv testing prevention
and treatment by visiting hiv.gov
gov